Berlin hat eine Mörder einem Killer aus
dem Rockermilieu Freigang erlaubt für
die Einschulungsfeier seiner Tochter und
jetzt jetzt ist er weg bis jetzt auf der
Flucht ja das ist eine Geschichte über
die man wirklich nur den Kopf schütteln
kann es geht um ihn hier um den Hells
Angels Rocker coraité der sitzt
eigentlich seit 2019 wegen Mordes im
Knast in der
Justizvollzugsanstalt Berlin Tegel aber
am Samstag da haben ihm die Behörden
erlaubt zur Einschulungsfeier seiner
Tochter zu gehen unbegleitet und ohne
Aufpassern verurteilter Mörder also der
im Knast sitzt eigentlich dem hat Berlin
das erlaubt was ganz viele Großeltern
und Verwandte während der kompletten
corona-zeit nicht durften zu einer
Einschulungsfeier ja nach nur vier
Jahren seiner acht Jahre Haftstrafe da
hat der Kieler Rocker Freigang also
bekommen und jetzt ist fehlt jede Spur
von ihm und die Polizei sagt na ja
vermutlich ist der denkst schon im
Ausland darüber sprechen wir mit dem FDP
Rechtsexperten Holger Krestel hier bei
Big live Grüße herzlicher Christel also
was ist da denn bitteschön schief
gelaufen kann doch gar nicht stimmen
oder ist das Alltag hier in Berlin
naja also man fühlt sich hier als Bürger
schon durch die Justizverwaltung auf die
Schippe genommen wenn man also hört dass
jemand der ein derartiges
schwerer Verbrechen begangen hat
mal
eben zur Einschulung der Tochter das
Gefängnis hier verlassen darf der hat
nämlich im Prinzip sämtliche
Voraussetzungen erfüllt genau diese
Vergünstigung
nicht zu bekommen sie haben es ja eben
gesagt er hatte noch vier Jahre
abzusetzen er hat ein
schweres das schwerste Delikt begangen
da unser
Strafrecht überhaupt man kennt und er
war zusätzlich schon mal
gleich nach der
Tat in Ausland geflohen er ist ja dort
hier in die Türkei hinein wahrscheinlich
sehr gut vernetzt und solche Leute
die schickt man
normalerweise nicht
den unbewachten Freigang wir haben ja
gut ja richtig und wir haben dies für
den kommenden Mittwoch deswegen
bei der Sitzung der
Berliner rechts aus ja sie kümmern sich
darum
vielleicht schon da wäre ne also die
große Hoffnung machen dass dann so auch
einiges nicht da klappt wohl auch einige
nicht
normalerweise werden die
rechtspolitischen Sprecher ja
unverzügliche NV trainiert
in diesem Fall Herr christliche Zeiten
ja wirklich ganz ganz viele Versäumnisse
auf
ein weiterer Aspekt in diesem Fall der
wirklich unglaublich ist auch ihre
Einschätzung zu diesem Fall das darf
eigentlich das kann eigentlich nicht
sein vielen herzlichen Dank für ihre
Einschätzungen an diesem Morgen
[Musik]